bu mesela konuşmama şöyle başlasam Ben
eşit niye İnanmıyorum ya da ben
eşitliğine inanmayan bir insan Hatta
arttırıyorum ben eşitliğine inanmayan
bir kadınım tam da şu anda bir çoğumuzun
aklında Benimle ilgili bir ya da birkaç
genellikle olumsuz yargılar oluştu
sadece ağzımdan çıkan tek bir cümleyle
Henüz bu cümleyi Neden söylediğimi
açıklamadan beni Kafamızda diğerleri
olur Evet ben eşitliğine inanmıyorum
çünkü benim için Evrendeki her şeyi ve
her canlıyı kendi getirdiğini kendi
özellikleri ve kendi farklılıklarıyla
eşli Biricik ve Yine geldik Makroskobik
olarak birbirinin aynısı görünen o
şekilde algılanan her
Ya aslında mikro boyutta farklılıklar
gösterir ve eşitsizlik denince ilk
aklıma gelen şey Matematikteki
eşitsizlik denklemleri sayısalcı olduğum
için herhalde ki en son 30 yıl önce
girdim da Matematik dersine yani şu
küçüktür büyüktür küçük eşittir büyük
eşittir şeklinde ifade edilen ve bir
çeşit üstünü anlamı katan eşitsizlikler
Atsız hepiniz benden daha iyi
biliyorsunuz Tabii soğuk mu konuyu
bunların çözümlerinde tek ve eğer ve
gerçek bir sayı yok bir çözüm kümesini
ulaşılıyor ve eşitsizlikler eşitlik
haline döndüremiyorum sadece yönü
değiştirilebiliyor çeşitli yapılan
işlemlerle Evet de bu konferansın konusu
Matematikteki eşitsizlik denklemleri
değil daha Global olarak var olan ve
sorun oluşturan globalde sorun oluşturan
sosyo-kültürel eşittir
Allah bilir işitir cinsiyet eşitsizliği
gibi olumsuz durumlar Yani bir tarafın
bir grup insanın mağdur olduğu mutsuz
olduğu acı çektiği olumsuz durumlar bu
eşitsizlikler eşitlik haline
getirebilmek için sürekli bir çaba
içinde insanoğluna projeler yapılıyor
kanunlar çıkarılıyor yasalar
değiştiriliyor önlemler alınmaya
çalışılıyor ama maalesef benim görüşüm
bir arpa boyu yol alınabiliyor olacak
bunu şöyle örnek yendi bip dünya
ekonomik forumu'nun 2020 raporuna göre
kadınların ve erkeklerin aynı iş
karşılığında eşit ücrete sahip olması
için geçmesi gereken süre alınan yapılan
yasalara Kanunlara önlemlere rağmen 357
yıl Yani iki buçuk Asır sonra kadın ve
erkek aynı işi yaparak ayrı bir de
kalacak ya da
çok değişik dizlikler de de bu durum
geçerli bir sürü çabalıyor bir sürü
Çabalar ortaya konuluyor fakat
matematikte olduğu gibi eşitsizlikler
eşitliği dönmüyor sadece yön
değiştirilebiliyor Bu da bu sefer
pozitif ayrımcılık sorunu ortaya
çıkarılıyor çıkarıyor Ali ben kadın
olduğum için bu ayrıcalıklara sahibin
gibi bir durum ortaya çıkıyor bu noktada
ben şunu düşünüyorum Aslında değiştirmek
için çabalamalı gereken şey
eşitsizlikler mi yani eşitsizlik bir
sonuç değil mi Bunu yaratan kök
nedenlere yönelik işlemler yapsak
onlarla uğraşsak çok daha kalıcı hızlı
ağaç çözümler alamaz mıyız Çünkü kök
nedeni çözmek semptomları çözmek
demektir aynı Bana gelen bir hasta ishal
bulantı kusma şikayetiyle geliyor bu
sezonlarda geliyor Ben ona ilaçlar
başlıyorum ile
çok seviyorum ishali kesiyorum bakmak
istiyorum ateşimizi düşünüyorum
semptomatik tedavi yapıyorum ama altta
bu semptomlara sebep olan hastalığın tek
şey olabilir herhangi Seviyorum olabilir
onu araştırıyorum ona yönelik bir çözüm
de bulunmuyor tedavide bulunuyorum Bu
semptomlar geçici olarak yok oluyor
fakat bir süre sonra kökeni çözmediği
için tekrar ortaya çıktı peki
eşitsizliği kök nedenleri ne olur Biraz
önce dedim ki eşitsizliklerden dolayı
bir grup insan mutsuz bir grup insan acı
çekiyor bir grup insan mağdur o zaman
Ekşi eşitsizliği ne denir ötekileştirmek
ve ayrımcılık olabilir ötekileştirmek ve
ayrımcılık nereden geliyor önyargılardan
mil yargılardan geliyor peki ne nasıl
oluşuyor bunlar yani insan doğasında
insan Birdenbire nasıl önyargı yargılı
ya da ayrıca olabiliyor
ve diğerlerini Kendinden daha aşağıda
görebiliyor Aslında bu da insanoğluna
dayanıyor Yani insanın gelişmesi
farklılaşması için büyümesi için Elzem
olan bir yeteneğinden kaynaklanıyor
ayrım yapabilme yeteneği Şöyle ki bir
Bebek doğduktan sonra testleri de
görüntüleri sıcağı soğuğu bedenini yavru
iyi gelen şeyleri kendine zarar veren
şeyleri ayrımlaştırma Rock ayrım yaparak
kendini kestim veba Yani kendi istediği
dışarıdaki dünyayı bu şekilde tanımlar
buraya kadar çok normal yani ayrık
yapmak bizim yaşamamız ve gelişmemiz
için gerekiyor Sen peki bu ayrıma
yüklenen anlamlar nereden geliyor işte O
içinde yaşadığımız grup ve topluluklar
otorite ve diğer enerji düzenden
kaynaklanıyor insan
bir grup ve topluluklar halinde yaşamak
zorunda olan canlılar Hepimiz bir grupta
topluluk içinde Yaşıyoruz bir aileniz
oluyor ya da bize bakım veren bir kişi
oluyor sonuçta biz ayrımları yaptıktan
sonra işte bu ayrıldığımıza anlam
yüklemeyi bu grup ve topluluğa otoriteye
göre al sağlıyor bunu çok klasik bir
örnek vereceğim Mesela bir erkek çocuk
kız çocuğun penisini ol penisinin
olmadığını fark ettiğinde yaptığı ayrı
sadece kendisinde farklı bir organ
bulunduğu Bu sadece bedeninde bir
farklılık yaptığı ayrım bu daha sonra
bunun erkek cinsiyet en ait olduğunu
öğreniyor Evet Sen erkeksin O yüzden
senin beni seviyor O da kız o yüzden Yok
buraya kadar gene normal Peki nerede
başlıyor ay
Şu an ne Ba Ba Ba göster oğlum amcana
tipine İşte Ah benim oğlumun da pipisi
varmış ben yerim senin bu plan şeklinde
şeyler söylemeye başlayacak çocuklar Bal
ben de çok ilgi gören önemli bir organ
var bu öyle bir şey bir anlam yüklemeye
başlıyor ayrımına bana ne oluyor Benimki
bu Ben de Ben bununla ilgili görüyorum o
zaman buna sahip olmayan bir Bu nedenle
ilgi görmeyen diğer insanlar yani kız
çocukları benim yeteneklerine sahip
değil benim kadar Üstün değil Ben
onlardan üstünüm ben onlardan daha
güçlüyüm artık burada kalmıyor tabi bu
arada sen erkeksin yaparsın Sen erkeksin
Gidersin Sen erkeksin Uçun benim gibi
şeylerle bu önyargı daha da pekiştiriyor
işte Burada Önyargı ve ayrımcılık
başladı Ben erkeğim onlar kadın Ben
güçlüyüm onlar
bu peki grup içinde tüm insanlar da bu
durum yaşanıyor yani ayrım yapmış insan
bu ön yargılar Her insan önyargılı ya
arkalı ya da ayrımcı oluyor Elbette ki
hayır belirir kesin belli bir insan bu
ön yargıları ayrımcılığa katılmıyor
verip fakat ortada şöyle bir sorun
ortaya çıkıyor Buna da bir örnek vereyim
mesela aile kız çocukları kız ve erkek
ayrımı yapmıyor cin-seddi bir aile diye
kesinlikle eşitliğe inanıyor ama kız
çocuğunun gece yarısı dışarıda kalmasını
istemiyor bu oğluna izin veriyor kızına
izin vermiyor çünkü kalıplaşmış trafik
bir düşünce var bu ne belli bir saatten
sonra dışarıda kalan kadınlar ahlaksız
ya da bir erkek eşine Eğer işlerinde
yardım ediyor
bu müzik yapıyor Bunun Ailesi tarafından
ya da arkadaşları tarafından bilinmesini
istemiyor Çünkü temizlik yapan erkek
kılıbık bunun gibi stereotipler oluştuğu
için kalıplaşmış düşünceler oluştuğu
için a bunlardan kaçmak istiyor Çünkü
neden grup içinde Kendisi de ayrımcılığa
uğrardı düşüncelerinden dolayı kendisi
dedi ötekileştiren ötekileştirilen grup
içindeki O yüzden sessiz kalmayı tercih
ediyor Peki diğer Grup diğer Önyargı ve
yargılara kapılan Grup Bunlar büyük bir
çoğunluk taneden büyük çoğunlukta Çünkü
otoriteye itaat Bahar olan şeyden
faydalanmak oluşmuş güçten faydalanmak
kalıplaşmış düşünce biçimlerini
benimsemek her zaman daha kolay olan
yoktur bu tip insanlar otoriteye ön
bu ara yargılara yer arşiyye körü körüne
bağlı inanan insanlar kendilerine de
benliklerine olan saygıları benlik
duyguları gelişmiş insanlar bu nedenle
kendini değersiz hissederler ve bu
boşluğu doldurmak için de ait oldukları
grubun Otoritenin kurallarıyla almak ya
da gücüyle almak isterler Yani şöyle
açıklayıp bu onlardaki düşünce şudur ben
sadece kendim olarak değil ben olduğum
için değil erkek olduğu için zengin
olduğum için beyaz olduğum için
Heteroseksüel olduğum için engelsiz
olduğu için Ard Doktor olduğun için
yapabilirim yaparım yetki bizim üstümü
ait olduğu grubun gücünü kullanıyor
ortam burada Kendimden bir örnek vereyim
ay yıllarca ve haya
o dönemde Ailemde de şöyle bir eleştiri
alıyorum Doktor gibi davranmıyorsun
Doktor gibi davranmak benim için çok boş
bir kavram ben bilmiyorum Doktor gibi
nasıl davranıldığını ve bunu şöyle bir
cevap veriyorum ama Evet ben doktor gibi
davranmıyorum Çünkü o derste o ders
okuturken ben kanki d358 yada kinkou
oynuyordu büyük ihtimalle diye cevap
veriyorum Evet böyle giderse okutulmuyor
ama insanlarda böyle bir kalıplaşmış
düşünce var Doktor böyle yapar Doktor
şöyle ben buna çok mutlu edin Mesela
buraya kadar anlattıklarımı
eşitsizliklerini kök nedeni olarak ön
yargılı ayrımcılığı Bir nevi açıklamaya
çalıştım ifade etmeye çalıştım Peki
nasıl çözülebilir bu kök nedenler şimdi
tüm yönetim şekilleri şöyle ya da böyle
yerşi desteklerler Neden Çünkü gruplar
çok daha kolay ve misin
Biz de kendimize seven bir temizlik
yapacağım zaman eve gruplara bölerek
temizliyorum daha kolay geçiyorum ya da
bu konuşmayı hazırlarken belli gruplara
bölerek hazırladım daha kolay birlikte
bildim Aynı bu şekilde tüm yönetim
şekilde Hiyerarşi destekler Bu nedenle
Bence burada azından yapılacak ilk adım
atılacak ilk adım en önemli süreç
bireysel olmalı Çünkü bulutları bireyler
oluşturuyor yani tümevarımla birşeyler
yapılmaya çalışılmalı Bu nedenle her
birey yargılarını önyargılarını farkedip
bunlarla yüzleşecek cesareti
gösterebilmek elim bunun için başlangıç
cümlesi Şu olabilir meteor elim size ben
sahip olduğu özelliklerle niye
birilerinden istiyorum o zaman
karşındaki işi de benim Sahip olmadığım
özelliklerle benden üstün olmaz mı ya da
ve bu tekrar tekrar hatırlatabilir iz
kendimize iç bir farklılık üstünlük
anlamına gelmez aynı çoğunluğun
yaptığının normal kabul edilip azınlığın
yaptığının anormal kabul edilmesi gibi
için farklılığımız yeteneğini
özelliğimiz üstünlüğümüz anlamına gelmez
demektir önyargıların kırılması
insanların kalıplarından çıkması
kendileri ile yüzleşmesi ve bunun
kitlelere evlenmesi bir sonraki kuşağa
geçirilmesi çok uzun ve zorlu bir süre
Bu nedenle bu ayrımcılığı önyargıları
Dolayısıyla eşitsizlikleri yok etmek
adına yapılacak projelerin de bireysel
gelişime odaklı Medya eğitimi kullanarak
bireysel gelişime odaklı uzun soluklu ve
mutlaka kesintisiz olması gerekiyor Şu
an yapılan bunları önlemek için
eşitsizliği önlemek için yapılan
bu çoğunlukta özel Günler haftalar
Affetmek gibi kamu spotları oluşturalım
oluşturmak gibi kısa vadeli projeler
yasa çıkarma bir topluluğa hitap eden
projelere Bunlarında etkileri genelde
kısa süreli oluyordu O zaman ben gene
şunu tekrar etmek istiyorum ben eşitliği
inanmıyorum Ay canlı doğuştan getirdiği
ve sonradan sahip olduğu yetenekleri
özellikleri ve dersler farklılıkları ve
her şeyin kazandıklarıyla ve
kaybettikleriyle eşim verecek
gezegenidir BP farklılıklarımız sadece
Bizi biz yapan özelliklerimizdendir
farklılıklarımız üstünlüklerini demek
değil teşekkür ederim